michael pineda a free agent to be at
season zen the trade deadline coming up
friday at three o'clock central time
is this the final start as a twin for
pineda here
in game one of the series with the
tigers one for four yesterday for akil
badu
to left center field and deep cave is
not gonna get this one that'll bounce
into the bullpen
a ground rule double to start the night
for aquil badu and the tigers
uh we've talked about him throwing a lot
of fastballs as a sinker right here
the duke good focus ball out over the
plate that he
puts a charge into one hopper over the
center field wall and coming back
to burn his old team the team that
drafted him
second round in 2016 left him exposed
in a rule five draft and the tigers more
than happy to grab him
another 3-2
got him a lead-off double but then three
strikeouts on a scoreless top of the
first
two away for willy castro castro went
one for three
with a double yesterday in kansas city
strokes one to right field
and that is off the wall kepler will
play with a bare hand
willy castro held to a long single
he hit it hard kepler played it well
it's a two out base hit for willy castro
squirted to the left side great knock
down by
simmons he doesn't get him and now throw
to third
got him
and castro trying to advance to third
after a great play by simmons if that
leaks into the outfield
a run scores they didn't get the out at
first
the tigers may challenge it but ceno's
arm strength paid off as he
rocketed a throw across the diamond
and donaldson leading off the twin
second inning
and that skips over the glove of scope
and donaldson
cracks a single to the opposite field
garber on the injured list for a long
time stepped back in with home runs in
his first two at bats
to right center field and d-pad off the
wall
donaldson to third they're going to wave
him around
throw to the plate is way off line
and garver rides in donaldson with a
double
donald got up i mean garbage got him a
2-1 fastball he was able to drive
didn't pull the ball shot that ball to
the opposite field off high off the
right center field wall for a double
and an rbi donaldson chugging along
around third
got in there for the score you get a 20
to one nothing lead
twins one tigers nothing derek hill weak
round ball left side sliding stop
donaldson from the infield grass throws
him out
the arms have been on display early
tonight donaldson
strong arm there ceno the strong arm
across they've got a young
nucleus in their rotation that will
serve them well in the coming years
drill to left padu won't get there
garber
rounding first will dig for second
trying for
his second double and he's in
one to right center one pulled down the
line a good night at the plate for mitch
garber
see the breaking ball hovering around
the middle half of the plate
carver crushes his ball over padou's
head in left field
for a second double of the night well
now
three on the left side ground ball
that's going to be a basement inside the
third base line
garber around third he'll score snow
he'll check up as first base as badou
gets the ball back in but it's a two-out
rbi
for miguel sadow and the twins lead up
now lead two to nothing
snow got him something he can handle and
hit that ball down the line
chest over the bag out of the reach he
only got a single but
you got to start somewhere garber scores
easily
hasn't walked anybody yet nope neither
is matt manning here's the 3-1
on the ground and that's up that hitting
streak now extended to 16 straight
for jonathan scope it's a two-out single
good for him let's hope it turns into
something
beneficial for the tigers and that gives
miguel cabrera another chance
here's the one-home fly ball deep right
field
that ball is gone number 495
and the tigers have tied it up
see what i'm saying one swing can make
the whole thing change miggy's fired up
it's been a while since he felt that and
that should re-charge the entire tiger
dugout
gets a fastball and he drills it to
right field two old pros
with two outs get the job done for the
tigers
fastball outer half miguel cabrera puts
on
a miguel caprara swing and that's above
the flower pots out there in right field
rooker polanco donaldson
a high blast to left field and the twins
have retaken the lead
again it looked like it went up into the
third deck
rooker's third of the year and his
second tank measure
shot in the last two games
[Applause]
111 miles an hour off the back off a
hanging curve
couldn't have put it on the tee any
better for him
his last two home runs probably a
thousand feet combined
here's donaldson single and a run scored
his first time up and a fly to left
[Applause]
a fastball you have to be ready to hit
it and josh donaldson was ready
for that fastball
the twins are up for three early in
their half of the sixth inning
fastball hovering over the middle to
play and just donaldson knew it
twins entered the sixth inning with a
two-nothing lead now it's
a 5-2 lead it's iricas
turns out one smacks it to deep left
field
that ball is gone oh he powered up there
eric haas number 16 on the season
what a greeting he has for tyler duffy
and it's now 5-3 one of the reasons
aj hinch has had him bad anywhere from
third to five as of late this is a
fastball that stays up
eric saw a few pitches from michael
pineda that were up
had a lot more movement than that but he
was ready and he takes that healthy
swing
getting word from the twins training
staff
rogers left the game with the left
middle finger sprain
and now robbie grossman that's why he's
been shooting
drives one deep right field way back it
goes
and that ball is gone we are tied at
five
robbie grossman's heroics in 2021
continue on the road in minnesota
that's amazing champion no more get out
the fact that
he's got a home run off colemay he's a
former twin they're very familiar with
robbie grossman in minnesota he steps to
the plate
after sitting the entire game he gets a
cutter down at the bottom of the zone
and he knows it right away
that's why you stick around folks and we
appreciate you sticking around
kepler hoping to break an o for five
right center field down for a hit
on the score and kepler walks off the
tigers
max kepler with a walk-off hit his
second walk-off hit of the year
delivering back in mid-april against the
red sox